Scientists have discovered a new insect that
has more legs, penises, and friends than me.
Great.
Hey creepy crawlers, Trace here for DNews!
In late 2016, a tiny new insect was found
in a cave deep within Sequoia National Park.
This lil guy was a millipede, but not one
scientists had seen before.
It came with 414 legs, no eyes, 200 poison
glands which secreted an unknown substance,
and… maybe most creepily, four penises.
This multi-genitaled creature, named Illacme
tobini is evolutionarily related to a known
millipede groupcalled Illacme plenipes, which
actually has 750 legs -- more than any animal
on earth.
And yet our interest still lies with, tobini
and his many peenees.
They’re located at the ninth and tenth pair
of legs, and actually serve a dual purpose
as legs.
Really working that old “third and fourth”
leg joke.
These leg-penises are called “gonopods”,
and are present on other millipede species
as well, although none with more than two.
But they don’t quite function in the same
way our mammal penises do.
They scoop sperm from another part of the
body, called the gonopore, and use the gonopod
to push it into the female millipede’s cyphopods.
Penises for legs?
Being a diplopodologist is way cooler than
I thought.
What is more interesting is that millipedes
aren’t the only ones carrying multi-tools.
The order of Squamata, which are scaled reptiles,
and includes all snakes, lizards, ALSO have
multiple penises, although, again, not more
than two each.
In some cases, each individual penis has two
tips, but that’s more like four tips total.
These two penises are called hemipenes, oh
and fun fact, they’re usually covered with
spikes and hooks so they attach securely to
the female.
So, why do these animals have so much to give,
whereas us humans, and most other penis-bearing
animals, have to live life with their one
and only?
Well, a study published in the journal Nature,
from 2014 has an interesting evolutionary
answer.
See, the Squamata order, and reptiles in general,
are marked by their amphibious nature.
Hundreds of millions of years ago, their ancestors
were ocean dwelling, and eventually they sprouted
legs, and crawled onto the shore, getting
the best of both worlds.
But that’s a pretty tricky move, things
are different on land than they are underwater,
and one enormous difference is mating.
See, it may be simplistic to say but if you’re
mating in water, you’re really just squirting
out as much as you can and hoping that the
water carries it to the right place; and that
tends to work pretty well.
On land though, indiscriminate spraying doesn’t
work too well, everything sort of just falls
to the ground.
What this study in Nature found is that these
double genitalia were based on the position
of an orifice known as the cloaca.
It’s found with amphibians, reptiles, birds,
and even some fish!
As an animal develops, the cloaca signals
nearby cells and tells them to become a penis.
Since reptiles evolved separately, their cloaca
is positioned differently for use underwater.
Simply put, penises on reptiles are based
on their hind leg positions.
So, whether you have one or two or four penises…
baby, you were born this way.
And this begs the question to me, why do we
even have sex at all?
Why don't we just breed asexually?
Find out in this video.
And let us know down in the comments if you
have any other new species you want us to
profile or science questions and please subscribe
for more DNews.